when he was kind of like getting at his
first school he was kind of getting into
trouble and stuff like I was trying to
have like a heart to heart with them and
I was like telling him I'm like hey like
you know like um your dad used to get
into a bunch of trouble too and actually
got kicked out a bunch of schools and he
looked at me he's like you did does he
even understand that you are also a
child too is he that age he understands
now he but he right now he's still stuck
in the mindset the tallest person in the
room is the oldest
[Music]
laughs
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys
today we um I wanted to ask you guys
what is something that you've said or
done in your lives
that you kind of hope your your kids
don't dig up and ask you about
oh [__] oh man any of the jkms that's a
really good pick like any of that dude
it's a good pick just JK in general or
just anything well there's video of me
talking online don't listen to it at all
videos I feel like it depends on what
stage because if they're like yeah if
they're like past college I think it'll
be hilarious let's say there's they're
in elementary school
that one's kind of tricky because it's
like how do you explain certain things
I don't know what depends what the thing
is
like if like if you haven't had a sex
talk yet and then they watch your video
and they're like like oh I saw you talk
about railing Mommy and putting your
foot in the back of her head let's say
that yeah I said what about things let's
say that your kid your kid who's in
sixth grade
goes hey Dad what is this stuff about
you eating out a hooker
yeah let's start with Joe all right
start with Joe
and you're on a rocking chair I
smoke your pipe
sometimes in life okay you could start
you're packing it you're practical
sometimes yeah you gotta [__]
Sherlock all sometimes in life
you're a charitable human being
good choice of words that's good you're
working and your job is service you're
giving and giving and giving
when do you get to receive
and this is where
I made the choice to give instead of get
and the kid stands up and he goes
and they stamp they stamp the metal in
the coffin
you know what's weird
I don't get squeamish like with family
sex talk that much because our family is
just like
been open about it my mom would tell me
like all those girls you bring home and
they better not be prostitutes and I'm
like what the [__] I got so mad I was
like you think I can't pick up girls on
my own
and plus they're like 16 and I'm 16 and
it's like we're High School like what
the [__] what do you think I'm 36
already yeah when I'm gonna be doing
that actively
because to my mom like not being married
and having sex is already a hardcore
thing right because she's conservative
as [__] so she couldn't even understand
that girls out there would just do that
I just like that she's not wrong she's
just early
he's so offended
[Laughter]
let's say you have a kid and your kid is
like
not as like humor Savvy and he goes Dad
what's so funny about this like like sex
in public prank gone sexual oh Jesus I
will disown them then if they don't get
that kind of satire like will you lay
you can't you can't you're dropping a
piano with satire on people's heads
especially growing up in your household
yeah if they don't get it me and Nikki
two are the most sarcastic people on the
planet yeah could only probably produce
a kid who has none of it probably that
will happen but you know sometimes kids
they just they just assumed some kids
just equate everything their parents say
is like that's not cool so they just
don't adopt it true what if your kid is
like hey what's all that [__] you like
you thought Auntie was hot
hahaha
I'll say Have You Seen Her
have you seen her auntie yeah come on
come on put Auntie on a trampoline and
try not to come do you guys have well I
guess
[Laughter]
I'm more cringed out with like if I had
certain belief systems or if I said
something about Society in my youth
because I was a [__] communist in
high school right and then like I just
had different hats throughout life that
you [__] believed in you know so then
like you would spew out all kinds of
things or just walk workshop and ideas
they're out there we've been online for
16 years so I don't think the same but
then there might be a video of me like
saying some [__] what I used to believe
what I don't anymore it's something you
took a really black and white stance on
yeah but now there's so much more Nuance
because you live more life in your life
I don't really yeah right I was a 22
year old [__] that thought he knew
the world and then like I had a strong
belief and I said some stupid [__] and
then like I don't you know like what if
my 14 year old kid saw that and go oh me
and there we think the same and I'm like
no no I don't [__] think that anymore
it's been some time now you know and
then they're like well you you said it
back then
and I think that's the thing right like
I don't want that [__] to go out no and
then they catch it and I'm like oh I
don't even remember but that's hella
embarrassing let's put you on video kid
and then see what you say 15 years after
look at how we judge the past right now
like even a hundred years ago dude
that's true like good lord it's crazy to
think about like do every one of our
ancestors too because we're the
survivors they were the rapists they
were the conquerors they were the
[__] Warriors who like killed the
other guys yeah the people who didn't
make it like are the answers to the
people who didn't make it they're not
with us so it's all the most Savage and
[__] evil mean people who reproduced
successfully whether people even wanted
to reproduce with them or not so I just
viewed as like dude we live in the best
time that exists if you want to judge me
yeah I'm a little comfort and a little
blanket compared to that [__] yeah so is
there anything outside of JK that you
would hope your kid doesn't dig up about
you and ask you about
outside of here probably not I think I
you've been pretty level everywhere else
yeah because a lot of times
yeah I think so I think so I don't think
I've really said anything crazy I think
what might make me like oh my God is
like what Joe was saying about the
things that I used to think were like
truth definite truth and I completely
did a 180 on now you know but there's no
evidence of that anymore like when you
used to say like Christopher Columbus is
the [__] yeah I was like he's the
tightest he's the sickest traveler of
all time most dopest human beings
yeah yeah best Discoverer ever ever and
he found America yeah he sure did and he
started the trend of naming ships that's
what I said that was that was that was a
Christmas
yeah you know what I'm talking about
that's pretty cool uh but yeah I don't
think there was anything
but I'm sure I could dig up two minutes
worth of stuff like I'll look I'll watch
a video for two minutes and be like oh
my God just from today alone there's
probably a really good amount anytime I
watch myself you know what I hope
happens what I hope happens is that we
have been so right over the years
especially in JK and [__] so like when
when when parents or when other kids
talk to their parents they see videos of
like them saying like uh you think
Epstein killed himself and the parents
and the kids like we all know that's
[__] [__] you Mom and Dad that's
what I hope happens but I know it won't
how did you know that
no but um I think when I do share my
past with him it blows his mind because
I think he sees dad as Dad yeah you know
so he just sees me as me the guy that
like sets the rules of the house or
whatever and then uh when he was kind of
like getting at his first school he was
kind of getting into trouble and stuff
like I was trying to have like a heart
to heart with them and I was like
telling him I'm like hey like you know
like um your dad used to get into a
bunch of trouble too and I actually got
kicked out a bunch of schools and he
looked at me he's like you did like it's
just like what the [__] because he sees
me as a rule person I was like does he
even understand that you are also a
child too is he that age he understands
now he but right now he's still stuck in
the mindset the tallest person in the
room is the oldest
because he keeps thinking even if
they're young they keep growing yeah
they were like he's like like trees yeah
because he was like he's like when
you're a grandpa you're gonna be like a
hundred feet tall
um afterwards like it actually get
started shorter
yeah so basketball players are old yeah
really so so yeah I shared like parts of
my past with them and then like I was
telling them about how like in third
grade I got kicked out and then I shared
the story of like
um how I didn't tell them like literally
what I wrote but I wrote something
really bad with the crayon on the ground
and I I explained why I did and then so
like as I share stories with them he has
these little glimpses and I can see how
powerful it is because it's way
different than our parents probably
because our parents kind of come from a
place of like I'm extremely righteous
put me on a pedestal you can't do
whatever and then as you get older
you're like wait you're a faulty human
just like I was and you could have
probably related to me and helped me out
and like but instead you're just
scolding me and having me having trying
to make me live up to something that you
couldn't even live up to that's true
yeah so I would say like if he did find
anything I'd probably try to use it as a
way to like explain some stuff to them
well fortunately you were never caught
or there's a mugshot of you with a balac
Avon or some [__] yeah
[__] daddy used to Rob some houses
I didn't share that part yeah yeah if
that ever comes out and he asks you
about it what's what's your go-to
explanation for that oh man I'll
probably have to say like
you know how sometimes you get like
really curious
of how something feels like or you want
to do something and you really want
something and like if I explain that's
like how like the worst version of it
that you can do if you're going to peek
at the Christmas presents but they're
not your Christmas presents and they're
not in your house
that's actually a big fear of mine is
like because I remember when I was
little
all those stories the intention was to
scare or to like tell me a lesson yeah
but I cherry-picked the like
I romanticized a lot of the things that
I heard from like my uncle my dad like
whether it was fights or crazy stories
of their friends
and those I glorified and I was like oh
I can't wait because in my head I
thought like a man needs to go through
dangerous situations to be considered
you went through life yeah so then for
me I just picture myself like my uncle
was a pastor and then he would be
preaching and doing his thing and I'm
like oh I can't wait till I tell my SOB
stories of how crazy my childhood was up
there so I started seeking out things
because I glorified the negative stuff
like fights and whatever he told me this
one story of like I was playing with
illegal fireworks and he tried to tell
me like you know his buddy had an
experiment he was making like bombs and
[__] and then one day he blew off his
[__] finger like tips by doing that
and in my head I was like that must have
been wild that's cool I need to blow
mine off
so I wanted to have like dangerous
situations to like I would wait till
like the fuse was that low and then I
start running so I could feel like
almost exploding and then like so I had
like I don't know this is why maybe you
shouldn't tell kids stuff but I twisted
looking back I twisted the narratives to
make it cool and heroic in my own head
they didn't do anything they were just
trying to teach me a lesson and I'm like
if I was that [__] then what if they
either if they saw videos of me talking
about the past or maybe I tell them and
try to like Mentor them about something
yeah and then and then they just take
out all the glory parts that they turn
into Glory parts
that's what's scary that's something you
can't control I know right yeah that is
true though like when when we had people
come to school and talk and they're like
I used to be a gangster I did time in
jail I'm like oh this guy's [__] cool
yeah he's cool and he's also cool
because he doesn't do it anymore and now
he's like reformed so it's like Wow you
went through the life and you got out
and he's safe yeah so he's safe yeah and
then you think I'm like oh man I want to
be a gangster just so I could not be a
gangster yeah because my my dad wasn't a
smoker when I was born right but he told
me the story where he was
um at the train station and he was like
anxious as [__] and he just kept smoking
he went through a couple packs and then
he passed out on the station and he woke
up with like an officer or someone like
slapping them awake and then helping
them on the chair and he was like after
that it was serious he's like I have to
stop smoking that's it's just too much
stuff from smoking too much I guess like
I don't know no oxygen whatever but he
just kept smoking right he told me
something happened and he was nervous
about it and all I took from that story
is [__] I can't wait to start smoking so
I can say one day I passed out from
smoking
the way that you receive info yeah I
don't think everyone's gonna receive the
information quite this so that dope is
why I'm not gonna have a kid I think
so I think I I started to like see older
kids and the cool ones smoking
cigarettes and I'm like can I try that
and they would laugh at me they're like
you want to smoke little kid and then
like I'm just there
I don't even know right yeah yeah I
could I could see that because I think I
used to also like if I fell off my bike
and tore my clothes I would ask my mom
not to fix it because I wanted yeah
because you wanted to be like this is
what happened I want someone to ask me
like yo what happened to your paint it's
a battle scar right yeah I think that's
probably maybe it's like the parents
lack of ability I think because it's
super hard to con because like it shows
how highly ambitious you were as a kid
I'm gonna smoke my life you wanna you
wanna achieve this but you think smoking
is the way oh yeah yeah but then your
ambition is high so you just needed
someone to kind of guide that like
instead of robbing houses like maybe
learn how to program or something you
know so I think it's just like like
there's so many ways to pass out you
don't have to smoke
it's baby and I think that's my
parenting's so hard because you gotta
like you can have two kids and like
let's say you have a Joe and another kid
you could tell the same story and one's
like they both have ahas but they leave
the room doing different things one is
like aha good thing you told me Dad I'm
not gonna smoke and then the other ones
like I wonder what that's like you
survived I think one of the best things
about not being a person with regrets is
because I feel like I can learn from
mistakes that I've made so like in a way
like to have a regret is almost like
well I didn't I don't really want to
grow I guess because I feel like I'm
always very productive with those things
like if I if I don't do something right
correctly but then I get corrected and
then I correct it I'm thankful that I
went through that you know so it's it's
tough for me to just go like yeah I'm
gonna have there's a value in it yeah
exactly and you have to be productive
with it otherwise
I think you can build misery with
yourself or whatever so yeah I think
it's really good to have um you know I
think if my kid ever asked me anything
I'd be like this is great because I can
teach you what I've learned about using
that momentum to like grow and and like
improve yourself really so even if
you're only fans model
and then your sons and daughters found
out they're like
daddy why is your finger bang your
butthole in front of the whole world
that's kind of
that's kind of was trying to get at is
that like we're we're now starting to
see people have to wrestle with this
where if they make adult content that
it's always going to be a big piece of
like basically as a kid you know what
though you're gonna I think it's
actually better that there's so many
doing it at once because they all have
to it's like a phenomenon that's it's it
it feels safer in numbers maybe but
don't be just more kids in therapy
really but at least they'll have the
same shared experience so it's a
community yeah instead of like one
Jezebel mother I think that's even worse
yeah dude Jezebel it's worse to have
less yeah I think it is because because
then it's like now it's really taboo
right oh it's kind of like if you meet a
parent from the 70s they're like oh we
were all hippies man exactly yeah like
we all did acid it's like who didn't do
acid you can't pull up videos of it
right that's the difference well you can
see video one thing is videos right but
at least there's a bunch of parents who
can be like yeah well we have sex openly
like what Mommy and Daddy do behind
closed doors we do high definition
cameras with lighting for everyone to
see but then there's always someone else
that you can judge it's like hey at
least I'm not the mule chick
[Laughter]
let's focus over there at the mule check
mail checks here by the way that [__]
got railed by a horse at least I'm not
getting railed by horses it's my own
husband that's what it seems like what
seems like the the higher demand in this
situation is that we we talk about the
things we've done in life and we're like
oh how hard would that be to explain to
your kid most of it's not that hard but
the demand that if you're doing adult
content right you just have to be that
much better of a parent to be able to
explain that [__] well yeah and I think
that's the part that's hard because not
everybody's good at that even without
that I think most people can't even
right they can't even explain it to
themselves or other people that's
already hard without a kid Yeah the more
lukewarm you are the easier it is to
explain it's like Mom why did you become
a pharmacist
you know it's so easy versus like if
you're like why did you become a drug
dealer dad and you're like oh [__] how
do I make this like a positive thing
because a lot of a lot of people are
being put to the test and different
podcasts like they asked this one uh
girl what she would do and it like her
response went viral because she was like
they're gonna go like well what are you
gonna do when your kid's just crying
about it you know and he can't escape
like the uh bullying and she goes well
he'll be crying he can cry in a Ferrari
I saw that and that is probably the most
out of touch response it's like it's not
that your kid is crying at all yeah it's
that you think the materials do
something about it yeah but it's like
it's a good line though it's a great
line it's a good line but it's a I've
never cried in a Ferrari
couldn't afford it nope but it is pretty
interesting that uh it is gonna
challenge you to like it's like the
price you pay it's like if you want to
do that you just have to be a really
really tactful amazing parent
when it's all said and done too well it
also depends too because we have um
what's her name comes in here and she
she like does feet feet picks no I
didn't mean her uh feed picks chick cat
cat yeah I haven't seen her yet but yeah
um you know that's pretty easy right
she's like some guys are sickos and I
monetize that [__] right and she's like
it's way easier to explain though yeah
but yeah she's not doing hardcore I
think it's different right yeah because
when you're out there and you're [__]
getting railed in a gangbang in a bukaki
show that's a lot different than like
here's feet it at least it seems like
it's different the thing is we we're
living in the generation that we're
gonna find out how different it is so I
think that's interesting because we
don't know the long-term effects we
don't know if everyone's going to get
out of it okay and be like you know what
life was fine like the chicks who were
in The the big dick gangbangs versus the
chicks were in the small dick gangbang
it's gonna be a lot different
I'm I'm well you have so many so many
women coming out saying that they regret
it or they're even you know the small
dicks gangbang or the big dick going
um definitely the definitely the small
okay okay definitely this is a small
yeah because the big ones look at least
there's some you know yeah some fun in
that because in the small the gangbang
like she I think the chick's usually
reading yeah she's like yawning all the
time she's like I don't think she knows
that this is happening yeah yeah she's
like reading like a whole book visually
sometimes you can't even see
and you're just like
yeah yeah
that's a good face it's really good
that's why you need the big dick
gangbangs because there's enough it's
more cinematic yeah yeah yeah they're
better and you're like I'm glad I can
they're doing more damage yeah yeah it's
like an old man with the big letters on
his phone so he could see it better
thank you